all right Kelpie and
Ashley and Chris Crystal yeah these are
my girls right here Crystal on the left
Ashley what's happening I'll try to
remember these names
um so where are you guys all from you're
from Washington uh yeah well I mean
we're kind of all around like I'm from
Southern Orange County but I kind of
bounced around central Orange County and
just like you know moved around my whole
life
um you could you're from she's from
Seattle but kind of like you know same
thing bounced around southern Cali
um same with her honestly
how did you guys end up in this
lifestyle
um that's actually kind of interesting
story like I kind of say they found me
like we always used to kind of joke
about it talk about it like oh we could
do this to get some money and things
like that we never actually took it
seriously
um but about two years ago I kind of
just started you know dipping my foot in
the game kind of like figuring out the
ropes and stuff like that and then they
were kind of short for money and I was
like you know there's some ways we can
get some bread you guys were in the
streets before this happened yeah yeah I
mean we're actually currently we're
homeless yeah so um I kind of just told
them like yo we can get some bread you
guys can uh you know your white girls
it's kind of a rare thing to see out on
the streets so we ended up just going
for it and Ashley and Crystal were you
working as sex workers at all before the
before we met him yeah
um no no I mean I like I tried to do
some things on my own I had a little bit
but you know nothing you need a pimp
yeah real talk so tell me why you need a
coffee well it's not just the security
aspect and like taking care of the girls
but it's just I found at least what most
of the females in my life past girls
I've had these girls
something about managing money is kind
of like it's a thing they struggle with
a lot for sure so I'm really I pride
myself on being like a CEO minded person
I'm really good at managing money so I'm
not taking their money per se to go
spend it on random stuff for myself but
I'm helping them manage it so that we
can put it into Investments things that
are going to make us more money things
that are going to look after our health
and all kinds of good stuff not just you
know [ __ ] yeah and you guys will
work where
um I try and keep them off the blade um
they have worked the blade a couple of
times but mostly I just try and post ads
and that's cracking since they're white
girls people want them so so the
internet is your is what you guys do it
yeah mostly just Ad work posting ads on
all types of different sites magazines
and it's it's working
you worry about the law
um I mean like I said I've been in some
some trouble before I actually just got
raided yesterday but um in terms of
getting caught up with the law on this
it's not a big fear for me right now
just because I kind of know the people
I'm working with most of the tricks I'm
kind of familiar with them you have
regulars yeah definitely regulars is how
we make most of our money I mean we will
Branch out sometimes but like I said the
regulars are really consistent money and
pretty much like three times weekly
sometimes bi-weekly things of that
nature
and being Caucasian you're you're I
think you're the first white pimp I've
interviewed yeah honestly a lot of
people always told me like oh bro you're
pimping you're pimping all this I'm like
you know what I wasn't really pimping
before I got into this this game but
when I actually got into the game I just
kind of like jumped off the edge and
just started swimming real fast I picked
it up just like I picked up all the
other uh activities that I've kind of
messed around with I just I learned them
quick I pride myself in being a very
intelligent person pretty street smart
and book smart so I kind of used that to
my abilities when it comes to this game
and other ones I may have dabbled in
before
and uh drugs are part of your guys uh
yeah we all um we're on different drugs
um they're using crystal meth uh and
that just kind of you know helps them
keep working but they were doing that
before they started working with me um
before they were in my stable they were
already messing around with drugs
um I personally cigarettes
um and opioids but I really cut back on
opioids a lot of just like you know
coding promethazine and percocet and
stuff like that but mostly just nicotine
is my my only Vice trying to stay pretty
is this just a business Arrangement or
is it a romantic aspect to this
um I mean I guess you could say it's a
little bit of both like I love both of
these women
um I mean we've done things of like you
know a sexual nature and things like
that but for me the number one thing I
focused on is the money
um and I'm sure they'll probably tell
you the same thing as they're really
just trying to you know have a better
lives for themselves and that in this
day and age really involves money it's
like the tickets of freedom is what I
call it yeah how old are you guys
um 19 they're 18. so you're all kids now
we're young yeah but we still about our
[ __ ] we still getting this money like I
said feds just took twenty thousand
dollars from me when they rated me
yesterday but um we're gonna make it
right back you know
and uh actually and Crystal you
tell me how you guys grew up and how you
where you came from before you got into
this situation
um
I kind of grew up in the valley like
Marina Valley and my dad lived in La my
parents weren't together my dad an
addict
um wasn't there a lot I haven't seen him
in many many years
um
grew up in a horror house things like
that so
a whorehouse or a horror Porter House
yeah Quarter House yeah yeah
um so
the independent thing your mom was a
hoarder no my grandma oh your
grandmother yeah we live with my grandma
I'm sorry right yeah and
um
yeah then
made our way around California
um my mom found another guy and grew up
in a pretty nice area but
um I always felt like there was
something missing or like
was in LA like I like kind of got
attached to that place and like I still
view that as like my home
um
and so
it's a nice city yeah it's a show a nice
city not really living though like
um
the like privileged life uh white picket
fence life kind of thing yeah yeah so
that's how I grew up I grew up white
picket pen Style
um until I was like I
maybe 12 or 13 and my parents divorced
kind of screwed all that up we moved um
more down south
Orange County
and then after that
I struggled with drugs and stuff so I
was in and out of rehab for a long time
um and then my parents uh
they sent me to like an Amish
type of
like a cold huh
yeah sort of
they were trying to
control you or just yeah in the right
right path yeah
um in the beginning I was just they um
put me in rehab for smoking weed or
running away they're like
they uh so they're they're very strict
very and you were rebellious
I didn't like to be told no I'd say so
then yeah yeah I think that's something
we all kind of got in common is that
like rebellious streak we've all kind of
strayed away from society's Norms in
terms of not just drugs but just the way
we think we all kind of have that
different mentality from go get a nine
to five you know hustle every day in a
legal way to get minimum wage and all
that we kind of we saw more for
ourselves because we knew we're special
people and so that's the reason we kind
of dabbled in this and once we started
doing it we realized like yo this works
for us so we're sticking with it and
just trying to go up from here you know
Ashley and Crystal you would say this
Arrangement works for you guys yeah it
yes is the best possible situation like
we all met each other at the perfect
time yeah you guys have been together
how long
um I don't want to say exact specifics
just because of the [ __ ] going on right
now but it's been months
um close to a year and we've been
friends even before that probably like
three years now so is that the typical
abusive pimp nah definitely not you know
what with girls that I've had in the
past
um if they get a little bit of a really
strong minded uh Rebellion then I have I
have checked a girl or two in my past
but kind of learned from that you know
the Gorilla Pimpin Style just doesn't
work I'd much rather you know just get
them to do what I want with my mouth
rather than you know slapping them
around and [ __ ] like that because at the
end of the day that's not good for
nobody they're not going to want to go
work if I'm beating on them they're not
going to look good if I'm beating on
them giving them black eyes and things
like that so yeah I just kind of tell
them like yo this is what I expect from
you guys this is what I want from you
guys a lot of times they go above and
beyond you know if they're not doing
exactly what I want you know I'll kind
of give them some motivation to do it
and yeah that's that's my main job other
than managing the money and keeping them
safe is to just be that motivator in
their life that they both knew that we
all need honestly
so your role is like their manager
you're their security guard you're their
everything like that yeah I mean there's
been times when we've had tricks that
are you know most of them are
unpredictable but some that kind of just
freaked me out a little bit and I think
it makes them have a little bit more
peace of mind when I'm there you know
you know just in a defensive way kind of
able to intervene if anything bad were
to happen have you guys had incidents
yet
um we've had a few people try and short
us on money but we always made sure we
got that right back and um you know
we've had people intentionally like you
know try and stay longer above their
time limit of the date and things like
that but we kind of just shut that [ __ ]
down and you know get them out of that
situation and usually move on from that
trick and just find a new one
so a couple of your style seems to be a
little bit of a throwback too like the
80s I'm 100 old school in every way and
the way I think the way I dress the
music I listen to because the old school
is the best school like you can ask
anybody around here and they'll probably
tell you like oh the old school you know
they were doing this wrong and this
wrong old school works this new [ __ ]
going around of people you know beating
on their girls because they think that's
old school and you know just putting
them out there busting cheap dates all
that type of [ __ ] it don't work like it
might work for you but it's not going to
work in terms of the relationship with
the girls that's why you see them
constantly switching hoes back and forth
because the girls aren't going to want
to be out there and not feeling loved
you know just having to do this every
single minute of every day and then you
gotta leave time for relaxation leave
time for fun and most definitely Gotta
Stay Fly
um their tennis shoe pimps down Orange
County oh you know what honestly in
Orange County I've met a few pimps and
they're all just gang bangers right they
don't even like you could call them
tennis shoe pimps for sure sure but
they're mostly just uh you know Chicanos
cholo gang bangers and they just find it
you know they realize prostitution is a
way to make money so they kind of get
into it yeah but it ain't it ain't a
real pimp in my opinion right a real
pimps gotta have love for his girls he's
got to have respect for his girls he's
gotta earn it and demand it but he's
going to get it either way and it's got
to be a good mix of both you can't just
be being on your girls demand and
respect because that ain't respect at
the end of the day that's fake and so
I'm just really big my whole life thing
is keep it real you know I don't like
none of the fake shoes fake jewelry fake
clothes that all these people be wearing
out there especially The Pimps because
they're just basically spitting in the
face of the culture and then face the
game and yeah it just gives a bad name
to all the other pimps out there
including myself a lot of people like
you know homies I've had and [ __ ] like
that maybe not current homies they're
kind of like oh bro you're a terrible
person for doing all this I'm like bro
you don't know the half of it like I'm
not saying these girls wouldn't be where
they are today without me but I'm saying
that I wouldn't be where I am today
without them and I think vice versa
honestly too
um and that's because I keep it old
school because I keep it the way that it
should be played this game is not
something that changes as the times go
on seems to be what people think but
it's something that needs to stay
traditional because that's the way it's
always worked it's the world's oldest
profession and it needs to be played by
those same rules that it was created
with
and you'll make sure the girls get what
they need in terms of drugs and 100 as
much as I don't like them doing the
drugs I would much rather go buy them a
nice meal than I would drugs but they
need the drugs to stay normal and to
work so yeah I make sure that they're
getting safe drug Supply and you know
all the paraphernalia they need to
consume those drugs is it difficult with
the two different personalities
um you know what they're they're pretty
close friends so a lot of times they
have qualities about them that will be
difficult for me to manage but I'm a
people person so I can honestly handle
that pretty well you know kind of please
both of them including myself and it
works out you know we don't have any
issues with that more than normal you're
still a young man did you have any idea
that one day at 19 you'd become a pimp
um I'm not gonna say I knew that I was
gonna be a pimp but I had definitely
like a personality where like I said I'm
a people person so I was kind of always
having girlfriends when I was younger
and even if it wasn't in a romantic
aspect like I just felt more comfortable
throughout my entire life with females
than with males so I guess you could say
that it was an idea in the back of my
head not a for sure thing but definitely
there did you describe yourself as
Hustlers oh yeah we are the number one
hustlers in Orange County for sure I
mean Pimpin is my number one hustle for
sure but in the past I've had other
hustles
um and I've always been doing better
than my peers like I said I'm making
sure they're living the lives they want
to live and just free of anybody telling
us what to do free of any roadblocks for
the most part
so yeah we're definitely the biggest
Hustlers out there how about emotionally
for the girls so they they get depressed
or angry anxious anything like that
um yeah I mean when you're dealing with
anybody who's addicted to substances
myself included if I'm not having my
drug bad day and same with them if
they're not having their drug that day
there's going to be a little bit of
attitude a little bit of emotion
involved but I try and just bring them
up you know like they're both beautiful
young women I try and just reinforce
that they need to love themselves just
as much as other people around them love
them and for the most part it works I
mean we all got our mental issues that
we struggle with whether it's you know
actual mental illnesses or chemical
imbalances or whatever [ __ ] you want
to say but we're just people you know we
got those types of those types of
problems but we make do with it and we
work it out what are your relationships
like with your families
um well I'm gonna let them tell their
own stories because I try not to I don't
like to talk bad about their families
and both of their families oftentimes
piss me off but as far as my family goes
um I had a decent upbringing uh my
family was kind of
like like hers very strict very
controlling
um and my dad kind of just allowed
himself to get bitched around by my mom
a lot and they were always fighting and
you know beating on me and [ __ ] like
that so not gonna say it was the
greatest upbringing but I always had a
roof over my head and food on my plate
and now my relationship with my family
they know what I'm doing but I think
they probably just don't really they try
and look the other way about it you know
like when the cops came and served that
search warrant the other day they were
they were on my ass about it but I kind
of like you know calmed them down called
him about it and told him like yo this
is what's going on like I'm sorry I
didn't come out and tell you guys
straightforward I kind of was under the
assumption that they knew
and Ashley how about your your family
you still speak to them
um
not really at the moment or I'm trying
to distance myself from them
um
like my parents never did anything to
harm me physically or anything like that
but mentally and emotionally
um they weren't really there obviously
my dad um haven't seen him since I was
really little so
um we've only had a little bit of
communication for a couple years and
we're both kind of ghosters I would say
hard for us to like keep that
communication fine
um so it's not really a bothersome to me
anymore as much like it was but uh yeah
I always felt kind of like I was trapped
yeah not feel like living with them yeah
or with my mom for such
um
and my stepdad I
am not fond of him really at all but
um
yeah so I always wanted to leave
ever since I was really really little my
mom would always complain because I'd be
the only kid that would cry to get
picked up from school because I didn't
want to go home
um
yeah so we got in a last final argument
out of all the millions and millions of
arguments that we've had that go nowhere
because there's that
emotional disconnect where she just
can't understand anything that I'm
trying to tell her
so
um she kind of gave me the go ahead and
I
um packed my stuff and I hopped out the
window that night and I left
they give you an inch you take a mile
for sure I mean it's much better I think
to be out on our own because like we are
young but we're adults and just living
with our families especially the types
of families we had it was so controlling
and so it was just preventing us from
doing anything that we needed to
progress in our lives so I think us
finding each other through fate or
through God whatever you want to you
know say how we found each other it was
a beneficial thing we're all friends
we're close we love each other and we're
kind of just able to you know progress
together rather than just before it was
kind of me progressing alone and you
know having girls and dropping them for
new ones and things like that but when
we found the two when I found the two of
them and they found me we really just
grew and we made a real connection that
I've never had before with other girls
what would you wish your families would
have done differently
um for me personally I don't wish they
would have done anything different I
think the way that they raised me built
me into the person I am today it
definitely built my character gave me a
good mind and kind of just look at the
world a different way so I wouldn't say
nothing I think what they did even
though it was harsh and you know abusive
I wouldn't change it for the world
Crystal what would you say
about about your family are you still in
contact with them
um
a little bit uh they don't really like
to talk to me
um
so it's usually like they won't speak to
me for a few months and I'll try and
reach out
um through multiple phones because they
block every number that I text them
um
but I'm not really sure our relationship
me with my parents is always on and off
it's um
like it'll be really bad for a few
months and then it'll be okay and then
it'll be really bad and they'll be okay
but what do you wish they had done
differently I
I wish that they just spoke to me when I
was when I was growing up with them
it's kind of they would see me
struggling
and uh
they didn't want to deal with it
themselves so they would put me in
like a place
where um
I'd get professional help I guess
rehabs and stuff right yeah I just wish
they would have touched me and tried to
just be there honestly yeah I guess if
yeah if I had one thing about my family
I'm sure we all kind of wish that our
family would had just been there more
the three of us because at the end of
the day if you don't have somebody to
count on you're gonna go look for that
type of Love somewhere else
and I think that's what we ended up you
know Finding not necessarily looking for
it but just kind of finding with each
other is that love that we never really
had from our families and that
connection that bond is it's something
real you know just because we're not
blood related doesn't mean that we don't
have that that same care and passion for
each other that our family should have
had for us
what would you guys say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
lives
18 years
honestly most important lesson I've
learned in my life
um it's not advice that I'm going to
take myself never have never will but
really just focus on the things that
Society tells you to do in terms of jobs
and careers because you don't want to be
you know walking outside to have a smoke
and you know getting put in cuffs cops
drawing guns on you undercover agents
and [ __ ] and they're running in your
house trashing your place just looking
for [ __ ] you know looking for taking all
your property you don't want that so I
would say you know stay in school
definitely just
even if your family doesn't love you
love them you know and that goes for
anybody if they don't love you try and
love them because you can't fight hate
with hate you can only fight hate with
love
and just being real to yourself being
true to yourself is the number one thing
in the world so follow all those rules
and you should have a pretty decent life
no matter what your upbringing is
all right
actually Crystal and Kelpie thank you so
much for sharing your stories yeah thank
you for having us wish you guys the best
of luck be careful out there most
definitely most definitely stay out of
jail I'm gonna try my best no promises
but I'm gonna try my best all right
thank you very much